valentine's day is right around the
corner and while it should be a day
filled with love it can also be tricky
to figure out gifts or a romantic date
night especially if you just started
dating someone so here with some helpful
tips for spreading the love is our
friend and etiquette expert sheila keys
to sheila thank you so much for being
here thank you julian it's nice to see
you again i know it's been a little
while we're so happy to have you here
and we get to talk about one of my
favorite holidays valentine's day so
let's jump right to it i think it's
always really tough if you just started
dating someone and you don't know what's
appropriate when it comes to your first
valentine's day yeah yeah there's a lot
of expectation there i call it the puppy
love stage you know you've just met one
another you're getting to know one
another so
you know here in time there's a lot we
can do but i often think you know go for
a nice drive go for a hike say around my
charleston a nice little dinner
somewhere set the expectations low
because really you know you've known
each other less than a year so you're
not going to run off and basically buy a
diamond ring straight away at least not
for the most part so you know keep it
low keep it simple some nice roses
chocolates whatever you know but keep
the expectations slow sometimes
simplicity absolutely but what about if
you've been together say a few years and
you're a little bit more serious right
well then you may even have set up home
together who knows you may be living
together so and who knows maybe you are
already engaged but if not again
expectations again are always high so
beautiful diamond ring for the love of
your life a nice diamond tennis bracelet
give the guys something nice as well you
know because we have to include them in
valentine's day it's not always all
about the ladies you know so come on
give you a ring and some diamonds so
maybe i need to let him off the hook a
little bit what do you suggest for a
newly married couple oh gosh again well
i mean you should still be in the throes
of wedded bliss right you just got
married so again nice simple supper
dinner at home go a walk you know on the
strip taking some views and again you
know if your honey is you know that way
inclined maybe a nice new diamond of
some other sort would work but
you know keep it simple you know we show
our love all year round not just on
valentine's day yeah you led me right
into my next question for you and
sometimes it's not all about the
material things it's about creating
memories together and sometimes people
enjoy more of experiences together is
that something else you recommend doing
yeah i mean john and i we're married a
long time and we still love going out
and doing spontaneous things you know
that's what keeps it fresh and that's
what keeps it happy so just you know
figure out what the person's like what
you think they may like what they may
not like you know so you'll get it right
all the time so valentine's day doesn't
have to be a stressful holiday i think
it shouldn't worry too much about it it
shouldn't be there's so much emphasis
put on it but you know if you love
someone you'll show the love year-round
that's what i always say well i love
that and like we said love is in the air
so these are some really great tips and
if people want to find you or reach out
with questions where can they go
www.sheilacase.com or
sheila etiquette so you can catch me on
social media that's where i am sheila
thank you so much you're going to make
my first married valentine's day very
simple and easy with your tips